Have you seen this map of all
the coups
happening in Africa lately?
A coup is where someone,
usually the military,
illegally overthrows
the government
and just takes over.
And here in central Africa,
there have been 11
coup attempts since 2020.
Almost all of them
have been successful,
including this one
that just happened in Gabon.
U.N.
secretary general is calling this
an epidemic of coups.
And that's
because when one military
successfully overthrows
their government
and the international community
doesn't really do anything,
there's sort of a
contagious effect.
Where would be coup
plotters in nearby countries
feel emboldened
to do the same thing.
The reason why
all of this is happening
now is because of a real contagion
called COVID-19,
which really ruptured
these fragile economies,
leading to higher prices,
dissatisfied people,
and creating
the perfect conditions
for the military to come in
and overthrow the government.
All of this marks a sharp decline
for democracy in this region.
If you want to better understand
international politics,
follow for more.